hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 2 video we got to be
Lonnie Machin anarchy
I'll explain they changed him from the
comics just a little bit so I'll explain
as we move through this so let's get
going real quick reminder - I'm doing a
reverse flash ring giveaway again this
week all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so let's get going number 5 meet
mr. terrific so the introduction here is
that Felicity is now officially CEO of
Palmer tech but they're bleeding money
she has to fire a bunch of people and
Curtis Holt here mr. terrific comes up
with a plan but because Felicity is
Felicity she doesn't want to have to
fire all these people so they say that
they're gonna come up with this genius
technology to save the company I feel
like it's pretty reasonable that we're
all in agreement that it has something
to do with the t's fears like the the
solution the tech solution that's gonna
save the company will have something to
do with mister terrific's technology
they said that it's not due for a while
so don't expect those to be a thing for
a couple more episodes but the really
fun IRL Easter Egg here is that as Emily
bed is like calling people into the
office to fire them this person here is
actually her real-life best friend I
think it's her roommate - so she is
firing her own real-life roommate it's
just funny that Emily BETT gets to fire
her best friend like hey why don't you
come be on my show I'll fire you that
was actually kind of a theme this
episode it's like a tale of two firings
people that take it vastly different
like Felicity's person that she fires
here takes it pretty well
however anarchy on the other side of
things doesn't take it too well when he
gets fired by Jamie a darkened hive step
into my office you're fired
so on to number four meet arrows version
of Anarchy Lonnie Machin there have been
at least four different versions of
Anarchy in the comics so what eras doing
is using the name of the very first
Anarchy Lonnie Machin and kind of doing
their own thing with the character the
two most recent versions of the
character debuted during the new 52
there were actually two separate
versions of Anarchy one was an
african-american just like a normal
person and the other was a corrupt
politician
so obviously arrow is just kind of doing
its own thing I have seen a lot of
people complain about mr. terrific and
anarchy in the comics just like them
being really great characters that have
kind of been mishandled so usually what
arrow does is is they'll take big
characters from the comics that they
feel haven't really been done justice
and they'll do the
version Malcolm Merlyn is the best
example of that relatively important
character in the comics but just hasn't
really gotten an awesome comic book run
yet so I'm totally cool with arrow doing
its own version of mr. terrific and
anarchy
now anarchy storyline as you can see is
something of an origin like this episode
just puts him on the comic book path to
wearing a mask they did say before the
season started that part of the fun of
the character is is that Thea as well as
damian darhk-- are gonna be partially
responsible for who he becomes so even
though he was already kind of
speechifying his anarchy philosophy in
this episode he is going to fully take
the Anarchy persona by the end of the
season they were kind of subtle about it
but you can kind of see this parallel
between Thea's character just going nuts
going off the deep end in Anarchy doing
the same thing so we'll have to watch
those two characters arcs to see how
they mirror each other during the season
usually when you like when you look at
like a member of team arrow for any
given storyline or arc that they have
there is someone else or a villain
character that also has a similar type
of art which actually kind of leads
nicely into my number three vote queen
for mayor so right out of the comic
books Oliver Queen gonna be running for
mayor doesn't necessarily mean he's
gonna win the mayorship but he's
definitely going to be running for it
so his mayoral arc this season is gonna
be mirrored by Dan Ford's character both
heroic characters that will have their
own ideas about how to fix Star City now
I know there's probably some questions
about Dan force motives like we don't
know a lot about her yet we just know
that she is an old family friend we
don't know if she has ties to damian
darhk-- or any of the the hype elements
in the city but don't be surprised if
she has like some twists and turns in
her character if she's known Moira for a
long time then she probably also knows
Merlyn maybe she was part of the
undertaking a long time ago we know
we'll find out Jeri Ryan gonna be a ton
of fun this season I'm so happy that
she's on the show she's going to
assimilate all of your hearts it's gonna
be so much fun and actually speaking of
assimilation just to make you know more
Star Trek references Oliver assimilates
in the flashbacks with Baron blitzkrieg
so this character here is Baron
blitzkrieg from the comics what they're
doing is is they're just using the name
he's not gonna be anything like the
character from the comics he's just
gonna be the big villain of the
flashbacks so this season long he's
gonna be the most evil person on the
island and it looks like Oliver's drank
the kool-aid
they flat-out killed the flashback wig
which I feel was an awesome move
the wig was just one of the weirdest
things about the flashbacks Stephen
Amell used to make the joke that it's
actually a Jared Padalecki wig just
because they're friends in real life and
Jared has like that really long hair I
think I mentioned it in my Q&A video but
amongst other things mysticism is gonna
be a big theme of the flashbacks
so in episode 1 where Oliver's like I've
seen some things man it's mysticism he's
talking about his time on the island
these flashbacks this season so what's
happening on the island is going to give
them some insight into the mysticism of
damian darhk-- and his powers but of
course on a my number one WTF moment
Thea and Laurel go on a field trip to
Nanda Parbat with a quick stop by Sara's
grave give me all of your dead person
diet jokes you need to get some more Sun
Caity Lotz you look like a corpse so if
it wasn't clear from like a lot of the
interaction between Thea Laurel and
Oliver Laurel had no idea what happened
with the Lazarus Pit she doesn't know
how it works she doesn't even know it
exists so of course she gets the idea in
her head that eight maybe we can do
something with Sara maybe we can save
her using this mystery hot tub that Thea
keeps talking about and behind the
scenes like they're the production
that's actually what they call it they
call it their hot tub set but now we get
to go see Merlyn and Nyssa we get to
find out about how this is gonna be
fighting Merlyn for control of the
league
that's storyline I don't know how big
that storyline is gonna be this season
because I think that John Barrowman is
still a serious regular but Nyssa is not
so they might not be around quite as
much as they were last season either way
we already know that Sara's gonna be
resurrected but it's gonna require the
help of Constantine and Oliver that
episode is not going to happen for a
couple more weeks so like the next
couple weeks we'll just be explaining
the mechanics of the Lazarus Pit why it
won't work beyond a certain point but
for those of you that are asking - the
longest time period that the Lazarus Pit
is still effective for like the longest
you can be dead is a year that's the
furthest out they've ever done it in the
comics and the longer you've been dead
the more serious the consequences the
the longer you go insane so if you've
been dead a year and you get resurrected
you will go apeshit so let me know in
the comments though like what was your
favorite part about this episode was it
seeing Anarchy get his origin story is
it seeing Sara's dead body I'm actually
really happy that they didn't make her
look super beautiful she's been in the
ground for more than a year of course
she's gonna look really desiccated for
those of you that are asking - the
reason her
dave says 2007 is because that's what
her grave originally said they first
thought that she died when the boat
crashed then she came back she was still
alive they just they never changed the
grave there was never a body that was
buried originally it was always an empty
casket so when she actually died last
season they just put her body in the
casket that was already in the ground I
think the only other Easter eggs that I
haven't mentioned are the dig at the
Green Arrow name like Cisco on the flash
last week said I hate it when they put a
color in the name Quentin also kind of
made fun of them putting green in the
name and then Oliver brought the fern
back so like the fern lives on into
season four so if you're a big olicity
shipper or you just liked all the fern
jokes from season three it has continued
on into season four who knows how long
it'll survive probably as long as the
show goes on actually I think the only
other weird thing that I wanted to add
AB note was damien darhk's policy on
kidnapping but he told anarchy you
crossed a line it seems a little strange
that a villain so big would get so crazy
over something like that
so you guys can let me know do you think
this throws any gasoline on the fire
that is the theory that damian darhk--
is Felicity's father like even if that's
not true maybe damian darhk-- has a
daughter out there somewhere in the
world that he's fathered that he also
feels very protective of regardless of
his own villainous philosophy oh and
actually really cool if you guys didn't
hear in my flash video damian darhk--
will cross over to the flash season two
just like the heroes will cross over i
don't know which episode it's gonna be
if it's gonna be the flare o episode or
something else but it's gonna be a lot
of fun so what's gonna happen next is I
still have a Walking Dead Q&A but I'm
gonna do a flash arrow Q&A for this
we're all named the the reverse flash
ring giveaway winner hopefully that'll
be out tomorrow at least by Friday so
why you guys wait for that you can click
here for my flash episode 2 video from
last night and you can click here to
catch up with agents of shield from last
night - thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow